hi and welcome to my molecular biology
playlist in this video we'll talk about
histone modifications which is the basis
of epigenetic changes
so we know that our chromosome is made
up of nucleosomes it's like a pedon
string structure and the nucleosome has
two components one is a histone core and
the second is DNA DNA is wrapped around
the histone core making these beads on
string like appearance
now inside the histone core there are
several kind of histones like H3 H4
h2a2b and a Linker histone H1 and
around this histone Optima the DNA is
wrapped around right if we look at the
structure of the histones we found
something in common which is a histone
fold all are
Alpha helical structure which is common
in all the histone types and the second
structure is the n-terminal tail the
length of the in terminal tail is
variable between the histone types
however the interminal tail and the
residues present in the n-terminal tail
are in which site for several
modifications and there are different
type of modifications which can takes
place in these in terminal tail and in
this video we would learn about those
modifications
so we should first ask two question that
how these modifications takes place what
is the context behind that and what is
the consequence of these modifications
coming into the first question that how
does these modifications takes place but
before that we should understand what
are the type of modifications that is
possible on a histone table
and here I'll be only talking about few
of these modifications which are
frequently occurring
um among these the most frequent is the
acetylation acetylation simply means
addition of an acetyl group onto the
lysine or Arginine residues on the
interminal tail methylation means
addition of methyl group onto the lysine
or origin in residues phosphorylation is
another common type of modifications
takes place in the
histones histones and terminal tail and
it mostly occurs in the serine OR
trionine residues
other type of modifications includes
includes ubiquitous Annihilation where
ubiquitin group is added to a lysine
group or ADP ribosylation where ADP
ribosyl group is added to the histone
tail
now first kind of modification that we
should learn about is acetylation
addition of a acetyl group to lysine or
Arginine doesn't take place
spontaneously
the acetylation on lysine Group which
would form the acetyl lysine or
acetylation of arginine which would form
acetyl-arginine takes place with the
help of an enzyme known as histone
acetyl transferase
this enzyme is very important in context
of Chromatin conformation and in a
second we would look at that
but the reverse reaction or these
modifications are very flexible and
reversible so the reverse reaction is
triggered by another enzyme known as
histone deacetylase or H jacks so hats
and hdax
kind of work in an opposite fashion to
regulate the gene expression profile in
a context and a Time dependent manner
so it has been seen that acetyl group or
acetylated histones are associated with
euchromatin whereas deacetylated
histones are generally associated with
heterochromatin state
that means acetylation somehow loosens
up the chromosomal conformation and make
it more accessible to several proteins
assuming this is a nucleosome bid on
string model where this blue is the
histone core where the gray is the DNA
which is wrapping around the core now
after acetylation it would repulse the
DNA and unpack it
and make it a little bit loosen up which
would make it more accessible to the
polymerase several transcription factors
and many other factors right
as a result the gene could be
transcribed and it has been seen mostly
histone acetylations are associated with
active
genes or genes which are expressing
now
how does these chromatic conformation
switch is taking place with the help of
any kind of histone modifiers like a hat
or a h deck the question which is so
important to raise at this point is
whether these particular modifiers alone
bring about these changes or is it more
complicated it turns out things are more
complicated because along with these
modifiers there are several other
players like the nucleosome remodeling
complexes both work hand on hand to
bring about this change in the chromatin
landscape about nuclear remodeling
complex we would learn about them in a
different video but for now let's focus
on histone modifiers we have already
learned about one type of histone
modifiers histone acetyl transferase and
de-acetylase which regulate the
acetylation profile on the histone
n-terminal cell and regulates gene
expression profile in a
context-dependent manner now let's look
at a different type of modification
which is methylation which is brought
about by methyl transferase which simply
adds methyl group onto the n-terminal
tail of the histone in same lysine or
arginine residues
now this methylation could be of several
types one type could be monomythylation
dimethylation or trimethylation so the
amount of time the methyl transfer is
engaged with particular residue
determines what type of methylation
profile would be achieved right so the
time of interaction of these modifiers
also
uh is implicated in terms of the gene
expression profile
methylation is both associate or
methylated histone is both associated
with euchromatin and heterochromatin
it's all depend upon which residue is
methylated because
h3k9 trimethylation or h3k27
trimethylations are associated with
heterochromatin State whereas h3k4
dimethylation or h3k for trimethylations
are associated with u chromatin state so
depending upon which residue is
methylated and what type of methylation
it is dimethylation or trimethylation
the state of the chromatin is governed
right
now other type of common uh
changes in the histone is
phosphorylation which is added by
phosphoryl transferase or phosphorylase
enzymes now these enzymes would add
phosphate group onto the serine or
trionine residues on the histone tail
now say both phosphorylated Sereno
triomine have a negative charge
and the DNA backbone is also having a
negative charge so there would be a
repulsion between the DNA backbone and
the histone in terminal till which would
allow this histone to get like relaxed
or like decompressed or in more
accessible to transcription vectors so
that's why phosphorylation is mostly
considered as a activatory gene
activator or a kind of modifications
though there are situations where
phosphorylated histones are found with
found in case of heterochromatins
and in case of like metaphysic
chromosomes and about that I'll be
talking later
in many cases phosphorylated histones
help in DNA damage repair
but we'll get to that point soon
other type of methyl other type of
modifications that can take place in the
chromosome
or take place in the histone is ADB
ribosylation where ADB ribosyl group is
added to the intraminus of the histone
ADP ribosylation is a common factor for
the heat shock genes following a heat
shock the heat shock genes would be
transcribed right and what happens
following heat shock ADP ribosylation
takes place in the nucleosomes in the
region of the heat shock genes which
loosen up the nucleosome allow these
uh hitchhog genes to get transcribed and
HSP genes are important for fighting the
heat shock response or initiating the
heat shock response so now we learned
about most common type of modifications
in histones now the important part is we
learned about the modifications or what
kind of modification happens in which
residue in which context but the
question is how inside the cell the cell
would predict that this kind of
modification is there so the cell need
to have a reading mechanism or a
predicting mechanism right so now we
would learn about the readers which
would read this kind of modification and
translate that knowledge into a
conformational change or change in the
chromatin landscape which would
influence the gene expression profile in
a time and space dependent manner so
first we talk about the bromo demand
containing proteins which normally
recognize a acetylated histone whereas
Chromo domain containing proteins
recognize a methylated histone now both
promo domain and chromodomain can be
present in the same kind of reading
reading protein
there could be a complex protein which
might and with its bromo domain can
recognize acetylation from one histone
tail and methylation from other histone
till so that can read as a complex code
right
so
there what are these Chromo domain and
promo domain nature of these bromo
domain and chromodom and containing
protein what does they do it turns out
histone modifiers could have bromodomin
as well because once they see our
acetylated residue in a Cooperative
fashion they acetylene nearby residues
as well and it has been seen many
histone acetyl transfers has this kind
of promo domain containing situations
other than that it could be
transcriptional factors or
transcriptional Regulators which might
interact with these bromodom and
containing might interact with these
acetylated histone and then interact
with the transcription Regulators to
bring about or modulate the rate of
transcription or rate of expression of a
gene eventually it these
domain containing proteins can interact
with several histone maintenance protein
such as cohesin or hp1 which might
further allow the further allow the
regulation of compaction of a chromatin
now how much the chromatin would be
compacted it would govern the gene
expression profile in that particular
time in that particular space right so
all the in short all of these kind of
modifications in the histones are like a
barcode depending upon the time and
space this barcode is also different and
all the mechanisms by which the cell can
read these codes are like a barcode
scanner each time or each barcode has a
different meaning and these meaning
comes with the context in different
biological contexts different type of
Eastern modifications would take place
and that would be read differentially by
these kind of reading machineries and
that leads to defaltered chromatin
profile I hope this explanation was
clear
and in subsequent videos we would talk
about all these kind of modifications in
Greater details and how that influence
in gene expression profile but for now
this was an introductory video to gain
your attention I hope you like this
video If you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe and in the comments
please let me know how you like my video
or how my how do you like my explanation
style if you have any suggestions please
leave in the comments because it would
really help me to improve my contents
and it would also help others right so
that's for now bye and see you in the
next video
thank you